we are here with reece witherspoon
now i actually um we do a thing here
called um the final five but instead of
me asking you we're gonna turn it to the
nurses in the audience and they're gonna
ask the questions
[Applause]
okay
all right alex where are you picking it
up with you go what is the best gift you
opened on christmas morning as a kid
oh that's a great question
i have to say the year i got teddy
ruxpin
does anybody remember teddy ruxpin
[Applause]
and you could put a cassette tape and it
would say the words of the story but
then i felt like guilty about it because
it was really hard to get a teddy ruxpin
but so i really played with teddy ruxpin
every day every day thank you alex so
much for your perfect question next up
we have our deus
right here what is your hello hello
what is your favorite outfit you kept
from legally blonde
oh okay
it i had it's actually from legally
blonde too and it's a pink suit that um
it's like a little twin set and it has a
pillbox hat yes yeah it's like chanel
jackie kennedy gary jackie i know
exactly the one thank you
okay next we have megan
hi
hi megan hi hi
my question is when is the last time you
almost peed yourself from laughing
maybe a few minutes ago
we don't know i have three children guys
um totally
i'm not sure that's what you that's why
she was asking me about laughing but um
laugh i just laugh every day i mean
literally i get so tickled thank you
megan so much next up sam
hi hi sam hi how are you you look very
cute oh thank you
i'm just saying dapper sam uh so my
question is what's one thing that you do
that embarrasses your kids um one
yeah
where do i begin i just i'm more i'm so
they're mortified by me whether it's
like i ask them what i always ask them
what new slang terms are like yeat what
is heat
yet i don't know
or they'll say like no cat
do you say that or is that nerdy i also
um grab my kids tushies everywhere
and then i'm also like i will wake up in
the morning and i'll be serving them
cereal and a song will come on and i'll
be like yeah yeah dancing like that and
literally they're eating their cereal
i love it and
i just think like you know i have this
theory if you're not embarrassing your
children you're probably not spending
enough time with them
do you know what i'm saying and one day
they'll appreciate that dance that you
did yeah thank you dapper sam uh and
last jackie
hi
hi jackie so my question for you is what
did you do when you were younger that
got you grounded the most oh oh um
definitely fighting with my brother
yeah and i also you know i started
businesses when i was a little girl and
i got
not suspended well yes it's been kept
after school to have to clean desks
because i was so creative and i brought
paint pens to school and i got them
everywhere because i started a business
out of my desk in third grade where i
customized barrettes and um i definitely
got a lot i got a lot of trouble at
school
well it didn't hold you back
now you have this extraordinary singing
voice i mean you won an academy award
for walk the line
and
i
there were two moments in that film that
really struck me it's when joaquin
starts singing as johnny cash and at
first it's a little warbly and you're
seeing like and then all of a sudden
it's like your skin melts off with
he becomes and he embodies he really
transforms yeah and when you come out on
that stage and you sing that almost
lullaby-esque song as june and we
already loved you
at that moment but the musicality of
that brought us in even more and i feel
like that's when people were like yep
this is getting the award there's no
question about that
when you matriculate that into a fun
movie like sing and you embody rosita
who just has the best storyline ever
when she's
doing like the gypsy kings and the
supermarket and finds her inner strength
oh my gosh just wait till you see this
next one what do we have to look forward
to because i have every song on sing on
soundtrack on repeat oh my gosh i've
seen the movie 500 times it's our very
favorite what can we look forward to i
can't wait to see you y'all see it
you're gonna you have to call me the
minute you watch it
i just saw it in a theater with a bunch
of little children i have never been in
a movie where i watched kids stand up
sing and dance at every musical number
and there was a little girl sitting in
front of me in her daddy's lap and she
goes go rosita
oh my gosh that was an entire it was so
cute okay well we have a clip from uh
thing two i mean give it to me now i
can't even i can't wait to see which one
is it
listen you guys
i have dreamt of performing in red shore
city since i was a little kid
and besides i just convinced my husband
to babysit for the next 24 hours and i
am not gonna waste an opportunity like
that
so come on
we've got nothing to lose
[Applause]
we cheer for rosita we cheer for you i
cheer for you as my friend i cheer for
you as what you are doing and changing
the world and putting out there
i love you very much very much
[Applause]
[Music]